[Applaudissements]
c'est lui écoutez buybuy vous va très
bien des petites blagues dans les trois
quarts du bas après ces îles et c'est la
bonne soirée
c'est la preuve c'est vraiment rebbouh
quand tu chantes tu chantes loi c'est
comme ça tout le temps tout le temps oui
c'est le problème après on dit que je
craque des circonstances atténuantes à
l'essai dans la vie on est là c'est vrai
que c'est dur
oui oui on dirait que je ne vais rien
vous êtes le plus sérieux c'est bien de
reconnaître deux amis joueuse de
badminton hockey bout
bah
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je le regarde à 2 de toutes les soirées
les habitudes ses invités se disent plus
elle va peut-être parler du fait que des
gens se reconnaissent pas pilote un
public et qui sont ses amis jolies
jeunes femmes ce qu'elles peuvent lever
leur moi non mais la sécu alors vous
annoncé en même temps